normally White House press secretaries
know how to lie in ways that are
plausibly deniable or open to
interpretation White House press
secretary Sarah Huckabee Sanders is now
just concocting lies whole cloth out of
thin air you might remember that
yesterday we talked about the census the
2020 census and I told you that Wilbur
Ross Secretary of Commerce and his
Commerce Department announced that they
are going to bring back questions about
citizenship in the 2020 census and I
explained to you yesterday this is going
to hold down the response rates of
minorities they will be undercounted
this will have the net result of
shifting money away from some of the
large blue states with high immigrant
populations like California and New York
State it's going to play directly into
the hands of Republican gerrymandering
and I also told you that citizenship
questions have not been on the census
since 1950 sarah huckabee sanders was
asked yesterday about this and she came
up with the really specific lie a
totally demonstrable falsehood that the
citizenship question has been on every
census since 1965 other than 2010 what
how did she come up with that we have
absolutely no idea here's the video it's
talked a little bit about the census
decision here I'm a lot of critics have
concerns that including
your question will discourage immigrants
participating you talk us through how
I'm just going to address those concerns
look this is a question that's been
included in every census since 1965 with
the exception of 2010 when it was
removed this is we've contained this
question that's provided data that's
necessary for the Department of Justice
to protect voters and specifically to
help us better comply with the Voting
Rights Act which is something that is
important that a part of this process
and again this is something that has
been part of the census for decades and
something that the Department of
Commerce felt strongly needed to be
included again what is the point of
these briefings when it's just lies and
no real answers to the questions right
that this is transparently patently
absurd Lee false and now that sort of
that that's the big lie right the big
lie is no this has not been on every
census since 1965 other than 2010 this
has not been in the census at all since
1950 that was the big lie there is also
a smaller lie she even though that was
only like a 30 second answer she
actually told two major lies in that one
answer she also said something about the
reason we put that back in is that the
Commerce Department wanted to protect
voters and comply with the Voting Rights
Act that's also made up out of thin air
this is all based on a letter from the
DOJ headed by Jeff Sessions remember
asking that the census add the
citizenship question back in on the
basis of a recommendation from John Gore
John Gore was appointed by Donald Trump
and is best known for Republican
gerrymandering around the country and
that's the point of this question being
added to the census earlier this week
the first question to the deputy press
secretary was why should we believe
anything that you tell us and I think
that the first question at every
subsequent press briefing should be Sara
at the last press briefing you told us x
y&z all of which were lies will you be
telling lies today and are you willing
to clarify those three lies from the
last press briefing that is how every
single one of
these press briefings should be handled
and I hope that today someone says to
her Sara yesterday you said that the
citizenship question has been on every
census in 65 other than 20 other than
2010 that wasn't true can you tell us
where you got that information I hope
that they will ask her that today yeah
see about that there's also some
low-hanging fruit here which is that
there was no census in 1965 the source
occurs every 10 years in the years
ending in a zeros like 2020 and 2020 and
that applies another survey but it
wasn't the census and we're sure that
there wasn't for some reason essentially
every year since 1790 every 10 3 10
years yeah listen that that is like a
tertiary lie at this point where it's
it's barely even registering and I don't
know if the unhinged degree to which
she's still telling these Germont
demonstrable lies is because she sort of
gets a kick out of it I've said it it
sort of looks like she really likes
bullying the press corps and just I
apologize for what might seem as an
unsavory comment but sort of like
throwing her weight around not literally
but figuratively or does she feel like
she's being bullied into telling these
lies by Trump or by someone else I don't
know but I'm starting to get emails from
people who say they feel bad for Sarah
Huckabee Sanders I don't feel bad at all
she deserves to have her political
career destroyed for agreeing to
participate in this no one forced her to
take this job hopefully Sean Spicer's
career is over remains to be seen he may
just be on a sort of political break
until he does his next thing but I I
understand how we might all feel like
some of these people are victims of
Donald Trump but she's one of the
perpetrators she may not be the top
perpetrator the perpetrator in chief but
she is a perpetrator here and I don't
feel bad for her whatsoever I think she
could be on her way out too I remember
in the last days of Sean Spicer we saw
less and less of him and more of Sarah
Huckabee Sanders yeah now it looks like
we're seeing more of Rod sha the new yai
perhaps who I also think is an absolute
disaster and would bring a whole new
series of comedic press briefings but
yeah I think that she is Trump has had
at least two instances major instances
over the last month where he's not been
at all happy with Sarah Huckabee Sanders
and we'll see how long her tenure is as
White House press secretary just making
stuff up out of thin air discuss this
with us on our subreddit at david
pakman.com slash our IDI di t next
medical professor donald light will join
me to talk about pharmaceutical industry
myths looking forward to that the video
you just watched was made possible by
support from you please go to
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
can make a pledge of as little as one
dollar per month and every dollar helps
to support the work that we're doing
particularly in light of the YouTube ad
boycott which has been really bad